is there something you could say
as a small side on how
smart contracts actually work if we look
at the code is there some
nice way to say technically what is a
smart contract
what does it mean to codify these
agreements the actual process for people
who might not at all be familiar
i i think you just write it into code
that operates
in this kind of decentralized
infrastructure you you usually write
code that runs in a central server
somewhere
now you write code that runs um across a
lot of different machines in this
decentralized way
and then after you write it you need
services and that's where oracle's come
in they provide all the services so just
like you would be writing code
in web 2.0 land running it on a server
somewhere and using an api
here you'd be writing code putting it on
a decentralized infrastructure like a
blockchain
or a smart contract platform like
ethereum and then you would be using
various services
in the form of oracle so they'll just be
called oracles or decentralized services
instead of apis
and you're you're basically composing
the same type of architecture
except it's hyper reliable at the moment
it's a little bit less efficient because
you know the
state there's an early stage to to our
industry
but it provides this extreme level of
reliability
and transparency which for certain use
cases
is an absolute critical component and
is completely reinventing how they work
so i i think people should look at what
are the use cases
where that trust dynamic can be so
heavily improved and that's probably the
ones where this is
maybe initially useful but i mean just
to emphasize i don't think
people realize when you say code that
we're talking about non-obfuscated
actual program like you can read it you
can understand it yeah
and it's there's something about uh
maybe this is my computer science
perspective
of like software engineering perspective
but there's something about the
formalism of programming languages
which enforces simplicity and clarity
and transparency and because it's
i've scene to everybody i mean
simplicity is enforced
there's no there's something about
natural language like language
as written in the constitution for
example
where there's so many interpretations
with the the nice thing about programs
there's no there's not going to be a
huge number of books written about
what was meant by this particular line
because it's pretty clear
like programming languages have a
clarity to them that natural language
does not and they don't have ambiguity
which i think it's important to pause on
because it's really powerful it's really
difficult to think about i think we live
in a world where all the philosophers
and legal minds
don't know how to program so i think not
all
most don't and so we don't often
see the philosophical impact of this
kind of idea
that the agreements between humans can
be written
in a programming language that's a
really transformative idea
that i mean yeah it's it's uh it's an
idea that's not just
technical it's not just financial it's
philosophical
it's rethinking human nature from a
digital perspective
the like what is human civilization it's
interaction between humans
and rethinking that interaction as a
digital interaction
that is managed by programming languages
by programs
by code i mean that's that's fascinating
that we'll look back at this time
potentially
as one where us little descendants of
apes did not realize
how how trans how important this moment
in history is
like human beings might be totally
different
a century from now because we codified
the interaction between humans that
might have more of an impact than
anything else
we do today you think about the impact
of the internet one of the cool things
is the digitization of data but we have
not yet
integrated the the tools the mechanisms
fully that use that data and interact
with humans yet and that's what smart
contracts do
you